uh the foreign ministers of qatar and
kuwait say there has been some progress
made to resolve the gulf crisis
qatar has been under an illegal land see
an air blockade
by saudi arabia bahrain the uae and
egypt since
june 2017. the foreign ministers say
constructive talks have taken place
between the four nations
and they all want to reach a final
agreement
president trump's senior adviser jared
kushner recently visited riyad and doha
for talks we have
achieved certain progress at a certain
point of time
more than a year ago and then things
have slowed down
and right now there are some movements
that we hope that
this will put an end for this crisis
because we see
and we believe actually that gulf unity
is is very important for
the security of the region for the
stability
of that region and for for the sake of
our people
this needless crisis needs to end well
kuwait's foreign minister gave a
statement a short time ago saying
progress has been made
constructive and fruitful talks have
taken place recently where all the
parties have stressed their desire to
reach a final agreement and resolution
to preserve the region's stability and
harmony and maintain the interests of
their peoples within this context we
express our appreciation for the latest
efforts by jared kushner
the u.s president's advisor well joining
me here in doha is marwan bashara al
jazeera senior political analyst
so how do we frame this marwan getting
closer
to resolution but just not quite there
yet
absolutely i think we're really getting
very very close
um this time around the efforts on the
parts of the kuwaitis as well as on the
part of the
qataris and the saudis are bearing fruit
the main issues have been ironed and
clearly the parties
are willing to open a new page if you
will
not to look back and to see what is best
to secure
a deal whereby there is no return
to the kind of crisis we saw in 2017
because
as you know the qataris feel betrayed
because of the way this has been handled
the disinformation the conspiracy
and so on so forth so hopefully a new
deal
uh a new page a new chapter in the
relations in the goal
yeah the main issue is ironed out you
say how might
the resolution look how would the the
issues and the challenges and the
problems
have been dealt with
well look what we know for that time
being is that the corner
negotiations taking place is between
saudi arabia and qatar
so that's where it's at and we as we
understand
where saudi arabia goes the other three
partners
will probably follow and the saudis have
are having their problems as you know
whether it is the war in yemen the
conflict with iran the gulf crisis
and certainly losing an important ally
in washington and
and and having the threat of a new
congress a new administration that not
that's not friendly at all saudi arabia
so clearly
riyadh is moving towards a resolution of
at least one crisis
one preoccupation that's the gulf crisis
i think
they probably i'm not sure but i hope
they understand that they made a mistake
uh you know that way and so they would
start paving the way
probably through some confidence
building measures like opening the
airspace and so forth
and then that could be followed with uh
some
uh specific bilateral
talks perhaps between qatar and the uae
qatar and egypt and so on and so forth
to resolve the other problems
i think what we have our hope we have
for now is a framework agreement
that they are turning the page and that
there is a will
if you will to resolve this issue
all right mom thanks very much more and
be sure with that analysis thank you